Oh. All right, guys.
And when I say guys, I think there's only one person on.
It's cool. It's good to have Hustler 80.
It says love is breaking.
I don't know if that means live is breaking. Oh, great.
Well, let's just try it.
Let's just try to do it, Zach.
It is what it is. It's it's live, dude.
That's the point. It's supposed to break.
It's at least you guys know, completely polished.
So we're we have four people watching.
If you are on this live right now, I'd love to hear just comment on it.
Just say something. You can say that.
Say, what's up? Say you can hear me just so I know who's on.
The funny thing about YouTube is it's a username.
So we got like Hustler 80.
You got all kinds of different names, but I'll call you guys by your name.
So we're just going to jump in.
I want to get I wanted Zach to get on this call today.
If you guys don't know who I am,
go watch some of the other YouTube videos that we put out.
I've been doing this business model of building simple websites,
ranking them on Google and renting them out for almost nine years.
Lost a bunch of money, made a bunch of money.
But I think it's one of the best business models on the Internet.
OK, I want to bring Zach on
because Zach does things a little bit differently.
Zach is somebody that I started working with like,
I think it was like two and a half years ago.
And he he needed to get out of his job.
He needed to replace the income from his job.
And Zach, at that time, you're making like six thousand gross, right?
After taxes, my job, I'd bring home like forty six hundred.
So, yeah. OK.
So he's making forty six.
The taxes are crazy.
It's making forty six hundred bucks a month.
But he's like, I need to get that replaced as soon as possible
so I can keep building my dream.
And many of you guys are in that same situation
where you want to do digital real estate, you want to do something online,
but you need to get that initial jail be nine to five, whatever it is.
Maybe it's even a business.
It's just not bringing in a lot of money.
You need to get that income replaced so you can then focus on other things
like building digital real estate.
So I want to bring Zach on because I've realized that sometimes people need,
you know, different ways out of the the rat race.
They want to get out.
And I think the best thing you can do as quickly as you can get out
is the method that you should take.
And so Zach has found this really, really interesting way
of of selling simple SEO services
where he has been able to scale.
Zach, are all of your deals, your fifty eight thousand dollars per month,
is that one hundred percent SEO?
I have one lead client.
For five hundred a month, everything else is SEO.
Yeah, that's crazy, bro.
I'll buy it from you.
We'll talk later.
So OK, so fifty seven.
I missed fifty seven thousand five hundred dollars all from selling simple SEO.
And I'm I'm I'm enunciating and I'm putting the emphasis on the simple
because Zach's strategy is very unique when I and the reason
I was a big you guys watched me for a long time, I was a big hater of SEO
services because I did it wrong and I tried to go land a bunch of big clients.
I had clients cancel on me.
I had this really bad experience and I was like, no, don't do it.
Don't do it.
And then Zach started scaling and I was like, well, obviously
he knows something that I don't.
Let's take a look.
And so we hopped on the phone and I realized, oh, he's doing this very, very differently.
So Zach does this in such a way, guys,
that he doesn't put himself at risk of like losing a bunch of business.
The other thing is he has his team that he's built doing this for him.
And on top of that, he actually has if he were to go in right now today into his.
Let's call it 50.
Let's call it because your deals are smaller.
So you probably have close to 100 clients, right?
Yeah, there's like a hundred and seventy some hundred and seventy.
You do like really small.
So, guys, you've got this business brick by brick, right?
Well, imagine he goes to half of those clients
and pitches them on a lead generation deal.
He's got a ton of money sitting on the table.
And so you can do this in a really strategic way.
Excuse me, that I have never seen done before.
So as a way to just add value to you guys and to show you guys
something a little bit different, I want to bring Zach on, talk about his overall strategy.
And then also the other reason I like talking about this is because SEO
is a part of what we are doing inside of lead generation,
inside of digital real estate, inside of ranking.
We have to rank the website at some point, whether you do it at the beginning
or you do what I do, you sell it and then rank it.
You have to do the ranking part to complete the process.
So Zach just happened to focus on the ranking of other people's websites.
So, Zach, welcome to call, man.
Let's just get into it.
I know you you've got we've got like twenty five minutes
and then you got to hop off.
And I think that's perfect.
So kind of explain to everyone.
High level, what it is that you do, like the type of clients that you have.
And then maybe we can talk about your process from like,
like, again, like a ten thousand foot view.
And then if people, you know, want to check more of your stuff out,
whenever we can let them know.
But just I want to inspire people that there's you can get your life
can change in a matter of 12 months.
And so let's let's just start there and let's talk about
let's talk about what you actually do, your business does.
Yeah, so pretty simple.
I started out actually 100 percent focused on lead gen,
building sites, ranking those sites.
That's why I still have a client like that I've had for years.
And then I realized there was this opportunity
because my dad owns a carpet cleaning company where
I built his website and ranked that well.
And then his friends wanted me to build their websites.
And it was the same skill set.
And I was like, man, I could see the path to quit my job
if I just stacked these easy website builds plus SEO clients.
So that's what I started doing.
I already knew how to build the websites.
I already knew how to rank the sites.
Now, instead of building my own sites and putting the money into that
to then land the deals later, I would just go
make money day one, which I liked.
I would just go get the deal.
They pay me day one.
Then my team and I build the website and help it rank.
And they just keep paying us every month.
And it was low stress because I would start out, just charge
three hundred to five hundred bucks a month per client
and just stack those clients is easy wins, easy wins, easy wins
until I was able to quit my job quickly.
Like, I started doing that
about four or six months later, quit my job,
and then just grew it a much more from there.
But it's essentially the same concept you talk about all the time.
I just tweaked it where I didn't own the site.
They own the site and they just pay me each month to build it and improve it.
And that's how I got the easy wins
because I needed the fast, easy wins to to quit my job.
And so that's that's the route I took and it's worked really well.
And then from there, you know, build the systems to get more sales faster,
more websites, build faster and just build it up.
So that's kind of the high level overview.
I want to go into questions I know everyone's asking.
Number one, does it worry you?
By the way, I've asked you these questions.
So I know you're going to be like, do I ask this again?
But from somebody that's just hearing you,
does it not worry you that your clients have the control
where they can just cancel at any point?
Why doesn't that worry you or does it worry you?
How are you kind of like hedging your bet against that?
Yeah, that's a great question.
Business owners need a website
and they need someone they can trust.
Most business owners, they're too busy
doing plumbing or electrical work or cleaning carpets.
They don't have the time and they don't want to worry about their online,
their website, their stuff online.
So they know they need a website.
They know they're going to get the website will pay for itself.
And if it ranks better, it's going to weigh more than 10x pay for itself.
As we'll go on Google, people just like when they need their carpet
cleaned, when they need a plumber, they're just going to Google it.
So business owners, they know they need a website.
And they're going to pay someone for that.
So it might as well be me, right?
Very rarely do I lose clients because as long as they're in business,
I've had, I've lost some clients where the guy's like, hey, I'm retiring.
I'm not selling the business.
I'm not, my son doesn't want to take it over.
The business is done.
And it's like, okay, now the website, you know, I lost that client,
but man, that's so rare because people are going to be in business
for five, 10, 15, 20, 30 years, and they need a website.
But it's, it's a pretty solid business model where when you explain things
well, people trust you and they just know like you're their go-to guy.
Um, now for these hundreds of businesses and they're like, oh yeah, it's just
like, it's a monthly expense.
It's like my phone bill.
It's like my TV subscription.
It's like my website.
It's just like, it's just a subscription that is mandatory for their company.
And that's why I love it.
Even if, you know, money's tight and they're like, Hey, um, we don't really,
we can't really afford this.
They're still going to have it up.
And there's, you know, I might give them a reduced package, but they're
still going to be with me because they need that website.
They realize it's critical.
So that's, that's why I like it.
So essentially guys, Zach's using his brain.
He's targeting people who are already planning on and used to spending that money.
Right.
If you've watched any amount of my content on this channel, I always talk
about go after business owners who are already paying for leads.
Why?
Because they don't need to be sold.
You don't need to convince them to spend money on leads.
They already believe in the concept and the idea of spending money on leads.
You just need to show them that your leads, your, uh, services are better
than home advisor angels, whatever.
So Zach, um, explain to everybody, cause you had a very similar experience
as I did doing door-to-door sales, by the way, Zach did door-to-door sales.
He sold a dish network and I wanted to tell you why he stumbled into this
idea of selling to people that were already using the service, but I also
want before he does that before anyone goes, oh my gosh, I, uh, I have
to have sales experience.
That's why these guys are, are no, no, no, no guys.
We, we, we just happened to do door-to-door sales, but we've seen, I
would say at this point over a hundred or hundreds of people that have taken
what we teach and without any sales experience and it made a ton of money.
In fact, um, Zach and I were just barely on a live like an hour ago with somebody
that had zero sales experience.
He's making $44,000 a month.
Did Vinny have any sales experience?
None.
No.
Okay.
So I just want to say that because I know that's what everybody's thinking.
Oh, it's cause they have sales experience.
No, we're, we're the anomaly.
So why should people, why should people target, target, uh, well, not why should
they cause everyone knows that, but what made you decide to start targeting
these kinds of people?
It makes so much sense, dude.
But when I was doing SEO, what I was doing is I was trying to target everybody.
Right.
I was like, well, I know this person has a business.
Let me see if I was pitching these deals where I had to convince them.
They needed, they needed SEO and they needed to use me.
And it was like such an uphill battle.
And then even when you got the deal, the first thing that went wrong, they were
getting ready to cancel the service because they weren't used to paying that bill.
So just tell everyone how you discovered that.
And, uh, I mean, it's genius.
And, and if you're doing it, Legion, if you're doing door to door alarms, door
to door TV, if you're selling SEO, you should freaking follow what Zach's about to say.
Yeah, this is like the golden nugget for me that finally clicked and everything
went buck wild, essentially.
I realized when I was in college and I was selling door to door, um, I was just
getting people to switch from dish network to direct TV or Comcast or AT&T U
verse, whatever they had, I would just get them to switch.
I never watched TV.
Like I didn't care about TV at all, but I knew that I could rebundle people's
packages or I could switch them over.
And they would go from paying $150 a month to 70.
I would cut their bill in half and they would get the same channels
plus NFL Sunday ticket, right?
And so like they're getting more for half the money.
And it was so easy.
I would just, I would make about 250 or $300 a sale and get like three sales
a day on average as a college student for a hundred days, I ended up making
like 70,000 in three or four months doing this and the whole idea was if
someone didn't have a TV subscription already, I would never make that sale
because you got to sell them on paying 70 bucks a month when they're spending
zero, that's a tough sale, but I could sell people, I would just sell savings.
I would, I would transfer people and save them money all day long.
So then I entered this same thing.
And that's what I figured out, right?
People that are already paying a company, a big marketing company, whoever,
their local dude, they're paying yellow pages, they're paying whatever for their
online presence, their website, they're paying, um, I don't know, Yelp, people
pay, Angelo's people pay for their websites, people pay all sorts of stuff
online, right?
I would just find people who are paying for SEO and give them a better offer for
the same price or a lower price.
And people would just switch to me all day, same concept.
And that's how I built, um, my whole company is just giving people a better
experience.
They're already used to studying the money, but why not get more bang for your
buck and just start paying me instead of these other guys that don't care, don't
know what they're talking about, aren't attentive to the details, don't have good
systems built like, man, I'm just going to serve those people all day long.
And it makes the sales easy and it makes your growth predictable.
You're just like, of course I can add five, 10, 15 new clients a month.
Um, because everyone I talked to wants to do this.
They're already paid just like direct TV.
They're already paying one 50.
They might as well pay 70 and get more with me.
Oh, they're already paying 500.
They might as well pay 500 with me, but get a way better website, a new built,
newly built website.
It's going to rank better.
I'm going to do their Google business profile stuff, which isn't being done.
Like there's going to get a better service than they have for the same price.
It's a no brainer and you just win people over all day long.
So that's how I think about it.
Makes sense.
And it's the same.
I had the same experience.
I won't bore everyone, but I had a very similar experience.
And that's why I always preach and say, target people that are already sold period.
Um, real quick, before we keep going, um, hustler 80 says, Zach is
selling low ticket SEO services.
I thought SEO was around 1500 a month.
Can you clarify if he is selling low ticket to get them to buy more services from you?
So in hustler eighties mind, that's he's never heard of SEO being that cheap.
Can you clarify exactly what you're offering?
Which, uh, I think is a good question by the way.
Yeah.
Great question.
A lot of people charge way more.
My expenses are lower than those companies because I have international people
working for me, um, which is awesome.
And so our profit margin is insanely high because our costs are low and
we deliver a great service.
But yes, we build websites and do their SEO and their Google business profile
optimization, usually for like around 500 bucks a month, some clients are more if
we're doing additional things and yes, we can then upsell them to, um, other
things that we offer, um, Facebook ads, like we've added other things on over
time, um, but it's those easy wins and then they stay with you forever because
you do a good job and you're like a great price and then you make great
money because you're smart and have international talent that, um, is
phenomenal and not as expensive as, as expensive as us labor.
So great question.
It's a business model that works super, super well because, um, most SEO
companies charging 1500, 2000, 5,000, they see a lot of churn.
I just have a lot less churn.
People are with me for years and years and years.
And I just, I just had a thought, bro.
It's kind of like what's, and this is to answer your question,
um, Hunter or hustler eight.
It's kind of like insurance, right?
So you, I'm sure everyone's act.
Have you ever been pitched on whole life insurance?
Yeah.
Okay.
Everybody has, right?
It's like everyone pitches whole life insurance because the insurance
guys get paid crazy commissions.
Basically whole life insurance.
There's a bunch of perks.
You can, you can take out a loan against it.
You can all kinds of different stuff, right?
There's that, which is what everyone wants to target because they get these
big commissions and these big jobs, whatever.
And Zach's basically the guy that's like, Hey, you guys can go and chase all that.
You guys can go fight over all the whole life insurance deals.
I'm going to go target everyone that has life insurance, just a policy, a term
policy, which is 50, 60, 70 bucks a month.
Why?
Because I know for me personally, I have a policy with Northwestern mutual.
That's like 50 bucks a month.
I've been paying for it since 2018.
I don't touch it.
I don't think about it.
It's just a bill that is, and I will always keep Zach would be the person
would come along and say, Hey, I know you already have term.
Let me show you how I can, you can work with me and it's a better option.
And I've already, I'm used to this bill.
He's not selling me on this additional bill.
He's just targeting people like me that already have term.
He's going for those low ticket, set it and forget it bills that are just a bill.
And he's just figured out a way to use international talent, AKA VA is to go
scrape the internet, find a whole bunch of people that have it go and, and sell
them on using his service, put him into, put them into his system and rinse and
repeat, is that, is that a pretty decent way of describing it or is that my way off?
Yeah, man, you nailed it.
Um, and the other thought there is like, you're building durable revenue.
That's what I love about this business model is it's a subscription.
Most businesses, service businesses, they got to go out and like earn
the next dollar every day with this.
It's like, you have a recurring client base that trusts you and likes you.
And that creates the foundation, but then, yeah, as you build your company,
you can upsell to other things.
And then it's like, you have no sales cost.
It's like all of a sudden, boom, you upsell them on Facebook ads or on, um,
your CRM system on, you know, whatever you want to offer in the future.
And you have these clients that trust you, you're in the door.
You got that easy win and you can stack that and make an amazing company.
And then if you want to crush it even further, like we're doing is like, cool.
Now these people that trust us, when they ask about whatever, boom, we can fulfill
that need and we grow with those clients and it's pretty phenomenal.
I think the hardest thing is getting the first deal.
That's why there are less entrepreneurs in the world than there could be is
people don't get like that first deal.
And so you want the bar, the barrier of entry in my mind.
I was like, how can I lower that bar?
So I'm going for the easiest wins possible to start stacking the money.
And that's how I quit my job.
And now we just keep stacking and then we stack and expand.
And that's how we build the empire is little by little easy wins.
Boom, that expand.
Cause now you have the trust and easy upsells wherever you want.
So.
Amazing.
Um, another question, what strategies do you recommend for attracting and
retaining clients in the competitive field of websites?
Well, first, just to clarify, this is the, we're not, I, if Zach reached
it out to somebody and they do have a crappy website or they need a website,
he'll offer it, but he's targeting people that are paying that monthly fee.
And maybe working in that, uh, that website as part of it is not just
targeting people that just need a website as a one-time bill, but I get your question.
So Zach, what are, what are some strategies that you recommend?
By the way, I dropped this already.
I'll drop it again.
If you guys want to check out more of what Zach's up to, he actually does
have, uh, some stuff that he, that he trains and you can check it out on
this website where he goes over like his A to Z process, but for the sake of
this call, what, what are some strategies that you use to attract or reach out
to those people that you want to target those easy wins?
Yeah, I love this question because the gears are turning, right?
And I think the biggest obstacle is irrelevance.
People don't know that you exist.
There's millions of business owners that if they knew you had the skills and knew
who you were and knew your price, they would go with you, but you are, you,
they don't know you, you are invisible in their minds, right?
So the biggest thing is just contacts.
I've used cold outreach a ton.
I have teams in the Philippines that call business owners and they
just find people that are unhappy.
Do they have accents?
Yeah, a little bit, but that's fine.
They're finding people who are unhappy with their current situation.
They set them up for my closers or used to be me.
They set up the appointment for me.
I talked with that business owner who I already know is unhappy with
their online presence, their website.
They're unhappy and that's an easy win.
So in the beginning I would do the, I would do the cold calls.
You know, I would just call business owners and talk with them.
The thing is just asking them questions and digging in when they answer the
phone to start a conversation.
Hey, see that you're in this area.
Um, I help companies.
I live local, whatever.
Um, what are your thoughts on like how you guys are doing online?
What are your thoughts on your website?
What do you guys want to do better?
Do you guys want to grow?
And if you start having conversations, it can be over the phone.
Um, it can be over email, but just learning about companies.
Now they know that you're even an option.
So I think that's to answer your question.
What strategies do you recommend for attracting and retaining to
attract, they need to know you.
So you need to do way more outreach.
You need to, if you're talking with five companies a day and not having much
success, go talk with 20 comp, 20 business owners a day, and it's
just a numbers game, right?
If more people know about you and know what you do, you'll get better at reaching
out.
So your conversion rates will get higher and higher over time, but
we'll even know that you're an option.
The biggest thing is it's like irrelevance or, um, not even knowing
about you, right?
You need to be known.
So you need to do outreach every day.
You or your team calling business owners, emailing business owners,
reaching out and Facebook groups, however you want to reach out.
I don't care, but you need to talk with people.
You need to care about them.
You need to listen to them.
And if they feel heard, then they'll listen to you.
First, you listen to them.
You understand them.
And then you're able to say, Hey, here are my recommendations based on what I
saw and what I found with your website and your online presence.
Here's what I recommend.
What's your current situation?
How much are you currently paying for everything online?
Oh, we pay this for this.
We pay this for this.
Okay, cool.
What if we do this?
Let's do this all way better for this price.
We'll start here.
Uh, once we know that down, we'll then work on your ads and we'll do this.
And boom, now you have another client.
So, I mean, a lot of cold outreach, if you join, you can join local BNI groups,
you can do whatever, but you just need to be talking and connecting with business
owners on a consistent basis.
And then your growth is automatic.
And one other thing too, just as I think I mentioned at the beginning, the thing
that you can be very, you can do is you can be very strategic too, at the type
of clients, the type of businesses that you actually go after and you work with.
So if your goal, you're on this channel, your goal is to actually own
assets and to rent them out.
That's great.
Go and get a handful, go get 20 clients that pay you 500 bucks a month.
You have a $10,000, $10,000 per month.
Your margins are going to be ridiculously high.
You're probably going to be making 9,000 of that or 8,000 of that.
Even if you have a VA and you can go now to these 20 clients and go and sell them
lead generation services on the backend.
So if you have a bunch of clients in the concrete space or the duct cleaning
space or the masonry space, et cetera, you can now go and you can sell them a
lead gen as well on that note.
What I was going to ask you is, shoot, I had a question regarding that.
Oh, uh, I guess one of their thought, one other thought I'll add to that is like
over time you'll get a better and better at reaching out.
Now I have very targeted campaigns to reach out to, you know, people that are
already paying big marketing companies and I'll get lists of big marketing
companies and we'll target those people.
Find unhappy ones, switch them over, switch them over.
I'll find people that are local to where I live in certain niches that I like to
work with, you know, maybe it's like HVAC companies are good.
Maybe I have experienced cleaning carpets.
My dad owns a carpet cleaning company.
I'm able to speak that language really well.
I'm going to pull a list of local carpet cleaners in Arizona where I live.
And now we have connections that those are easy wins.
So think about your strengths and think about how you can get easy
wins and easy switches to you.
And you'll just stack a monthly recurring revenue.
The other thing about SEO is every single person on this planet that owns
a business you can sell to right at the right price, you can sell SEO to anybody.
And I'm not saying that you should, but you could sell SEO to the person that
owns this company that makes these water bottles or the person that cleans this
office, you know, with lead generation, you have to be a lot more targeted.
So it is nice because anybody that you talk to, even if let's say you, you, you
find somebody, you can sell them SEO, but it's a really competitive city.
It doesn't matter because as long as you charge enough money for that SEO,
you're you it's still money.
Um, so anyway, that's number one.
Number two is I remember when I was going to ask you real quick, and I know you
got to get off for a second, but what is your pro on an average client?
What's your profit margin?
Let's say you make it 500 bucks a month gross.
How much of that are you putting in your pocket out of your 58,000 a month?
How much of that is, is actual profit?
So, yeah, great question.
In the beginning, it was a lot higher, um, because I was doing the sales.
I was, um, involved in the business more.
It was like 70 or 80% profit margin.
Now, um, I have like an SDR team, a sales team, um, website building team, SEO
team, everything's built and just runs.
Um, you know, I have the support team, everything is just dialed in, um, day
to day, there's not honestly a ton for me to do except new things that I want to
implement margin is like 30, 40%.
Um, so, and on top of that, we cross sell our clients to other businesses with
high profit margins, more like the 70, 80% profit margins.
Um, so yeah, it's a pretty good, pretty good system.
If you, by the way, last thing I want to say, uh, hustler 80, for example,
if you were to go and build a business right now of 20 clients, 500 bucks a
month average client, you were going to do all the work.
You could probably have 90% profit margins.
Like that's not unrealistic.
You wouldn't be doing the work.
You wouldn't be doing the updates on the websites, but that'd be manageable.
Once you start to scale, you're going to have to bring on people.
You're going to have to put in systems.
You're going to have to do some of these things.
And as you scale, your profits going to go down, but you're also scaling.
And, and I know Zach, for example, he doesn't have to do a lot of
the actual work himself.
So anyway, Zach has got to jump onto another call here in three minutes.
I'm going to let him go.
But guys, if you want to check out more of what Zach's up to, go to Zach pile.co.
I dropped it a couple of times in the chat.
Hustler 80s had got his grade.
I've been searching for SEO coach like Zach, and here he is live right on my
break at work on a crazy coincidence.
Either that's crazy or this guy's messing with us, but either way, that's cool.
He might just, he might be feeding us, but, um, yeah, hustler 80 reach out to Zach.
Maybe mention that your username is hustler 80.
Appreciate you being on.
Appreciate everybody being on guys.
See your 20, 25, get out of the rat race.
It's God didn't put you on this earth to just be under someone's thumb.
Get your freedom and live the life you want to live.
Zach, thanks for being on the call.
We'll see you guys when I go live again.
Thanks man.
Thanks Nick.
Later.